you
she's a girl among all these dudes and
she's like kicking butt she's really
awesome and she's very fun to read the
lasso of truth is really cool the fact
that she can fly super string she is
perfect for the past 75 years she's been
the most recognizable female comic book
character she's had her own stories told
continuously in a variety of formats
from comic books to TV series two films
and of course in video games like DC
Universe Online rolling I must warn you
Athena my friends are very strong let's
get it like a year like you're exerting
yourself your day you've got the
Minotaur and trying to push him over
he's heavy it's the one of the big
minute worse okay Wonder Woman means
well she's a gift to me she's been a
gift because I was given a job to give
her voice and I've been doing it for
about 16 years and to be able to be
associated with a character that is so
beloved not just in this country but
throughout the world that is a present
it was bestowed on me and so I feel an
obligation to do her justice part in the
poem and to represent her well Hera give
me strength excellent that's great I
mum's dad gave it to her thoughts nope
no excellent there's Beauty wrap I think
that's good Wonder Woman is fascinating
because her appearance in October of
1941 predates Pearl Harbor but here you
have this incredibly patriotic character
he was going to soon be battling Nazi
saboteurs across the country the fact
that she's an Amazon she's an outsider
and she's looking at our society our
beliefs almost with this innocent
childlike quality she doesn't
necessarily understand it all because
she's been raised in a virtual utopia no
violence there's very little death she's
always there she's always protective
she's never bitter she's never mean
personally she's always been there for
the people that are close to them
under woman instances everybody so
that's a gift to have men and women come
up to your children older people younger
people who love the character we wanted
that Wonder Woman that you think of when
you when you're just sitting there you
close your eyes you imagine Wonder Woman
that's who you're get to be within our
game one a woman is important to the
game but she's also very important to me
personally growing up I felt like it was
a hero I could identify with she wasn't
like a derivative of another character
she was her own hero and she was very
confident with her own strength which
helped me learn to be confident with
mine so one of the deal sees that I was
most excited to work on was sons of
trigon because that's the one where that
relationship really developed with crc
this this anger and like resentment they
have for each other and one of the first
times I got to really sit down and work
with Susan Eisenberg by the Thunderbolt
of Zeus I am thrilled to be celebrating
Wonder Woman's 75th anniversary I'm
really excited to be celebrating the
75th anniversary with Susan and Jack I'm
a part of that 75 years we all are
that's amazing I am so proud and
thrilled and delighted to be part of
Wonder Woman 75th anniversary
celebration great Hera